[Musique]
l'institut photovoltaïque d'île de
france c'est un tout jeune institut
puisqu'il a été créé à peine trois ans
avec comme ambition de d'agréger et de
fédérer les efforts de recherche de ses
partenaires dans le domaine des cellules
photovoltaïques avec mon ambition d'
activer des leviers de partage des coûts
de la recherche et des leviers de
développement d'innovation en regroupant
dans un même mieux des chercheurs de
culture et de savoir faire différent
donc l'objectif de l'institut et de
développer les cellules photovoltaïques
de demain laissez nous travailler sur
l'amélioration de leur performance les
rendements leur capacité à transformer
énergie du soleil en électricité est
également de réduire leurs coûts de
façon à poursuivre les efforts qui ont
été faits jusqu'à aujourd'hui en termes
de compétitivité de cette filière de
production mais de rendre encore moins
cher les panneaux photovoltaïques
convient juste de regrouper ici au coeur
du campus de paris saclay a pas d eau
dans ce nouveau bâtiment que nous venons
de réceptionner une centaine de
chercheurs demain sans doute deux sens
et qui vont travailler ensemble dans un
même programme de recherche qui vise à
développer ces cellules de rupture est
partenaire de l'ipb f sont edf et total
le cnrs l'école polytechnique associé à
air liquide et puis deux équipementiers
du domaine photovoltaïque horiba et
riber est donc on retrouve la plupart de
ses partenaires sur le campus de paris
saclay et notre présence
si à palaiseau va permettre d'amplifier
nono collaboration avec ses partenaires
avec des échanges de chercheurs d
partage d'équipements de recherche sur
le campus qui l'élève soit élargir son
partenariat de nouveaux acteurs qu'ils
soient locaux ou nationaux ou
internationaux et les avants d'ailleurs
réservé une partie du bâtiment à ces
nouveaux entrants de façon à ce qu'ils
puissent tenir en tant que chercheur ou
même venir avec des équipements de
recherche puisqu'on a réservé une partie
de nos laboratoires à ses nouveaux
partenaires de façon à ce qu'ils
puissent venir contribuer à l'arrêt
nation d'un programme de recherche et
les accélérer